now we'd like you to write this flip
book animation style in code we've given
you a list of image assets to use for
evil devices what you need to do is load
all of these image assets and place them
in the frame array after your images are
loaded you should go through and fill
out the rest of the animation function
here which will actually draw the flip
book animation images to the screen as
we described before make sure that when
your animation is finishing loop back to
the beginning now before this you need
to have some logic that checks for
whether or not the images are loaded and
once all of the frames have been loaded
actually does a call to set interval now
set interval takes as input a pointer to
a function you'd like to call as well as
a millisecond count on how often you
want it to be called so for instance if
I made a function and wanted it to be
called once every 30 milliseconds those
would be parameters that I pass into it
make sure that your set interval call
actually calls the animate function once
every 30 milliseconds